if this tournament was a movie what
genre would it be horror comedy drama um
I don't know I hope it's really exciting
I hope it's like some new type of genre
which combines many different genres
together I'd probably go for the drama
route I don't know last year was
probably a better candidate for the
drama route but I don't know hey I have
to see you suspense
hopefully horror movie many mistakes in
crazy games not a horror movie maybe
there could be some comedy I hope I
don't see how it could be romantic
comedy but who knows either an action or
a thriller the comedy way the little
drama so much drama going on I can
already imagine it
so last rows of thriller I think this
year will be more of a drama I think the
winning score will probably be pretty
low I don't think they're gonna be a lot
of decisive games I mean I would see
drama Vasek the obvious answer so maybe
like comedy for me it'll probably be a
horror movie I don't know probably some
kind of drama about beating the odds
again hopefully like a documentary like
cut and dry you did well usually until
then you don't really know what's gonna
happen so suspense also is very fitting
I would say I would be a drama so I
think it's gonna be drama just because I
figure there will be a lot of people in
the hunt do me now it seems that it's
going to be suspense
I think chess is probably a mixture of
tragedy and comedy
you